so James Woods Hollywood actor for
movies like contact and casino he's done
voices in the Simpsons family Guy in a
zillion other things he's taken a sort
of hard turn right politically and he
shared his thoughts on Twitter and
people are not happy with them let's
read some of the tweets this president
is a true abomination to have barricaded
the World War two vets but allowing
illegal aliens privilege and then
there's a line I think we got are you
kidding me I could actually read that oh
my god
I think we got a couple more here then
so then people in writing him saying
this person said dude aren't you worried
about you know ever working again
because Hollywood is such a liberal
elitist town and he wrote I don't expect
to work again I think Barack Obama is a
threat to the integrity and future of
the Republic my country first so just
real quick I do want to tell you that I
asked James Woods to be on the show and
he said he'd like to do it but he only
wants to stick to Twitter where he can
control the message right now as opposed
to you come here really thank you and we
can edit it and really screw you up
Oh God I sort of even though I don't
agree with a lot of what he's doing I
sort of respect that he's putting
himself out there and we have so few
people in the public sphere that do do
that Jimmy you're I can sense a headache
coming well I mean I expect someone
taking a courageous stand that's not a
courageous stand to side with racists
and [ __ ] and it's safe to just sling
unsubstantiated crap
the last president we all accept the
fact that him and his team lied us into
an illegal [ __ ] war but somehow
national health insurance is going to
subvert democracy right so that's the
kind of just like go away you're just an
idiot it's gets this that's not that's
what I'm talking about we have to have
an agreed set of facts to do we deal
with so if you're going to say that
first of all he didn't close the goddamn
memorial the [ __ ] Republicans closed
down that's all right that's part of the
goddamn fence I mean Ellen they do that
and I saw something but it was upset
about the World War Two memorial but
he's not upset about the cancer patients
who are gonna get their trials he's not
upset about the kids on WIC who are
gonna get their formula he's upset about
the World War two music which shows what
a [ __ ] lightweight he is James Woods
turns out having all the money in the
world
doesn't make you a good person right
exactly do you think he's gonna be able
to work again when you do this in
Hollywood well we're all you know oh
it's you know plenty he'll never work
again just like Mel Gibson right exactly
what exact up but he doesn't work that
well he works he does work they can work
yeah you don't want anytime anybody can
make anybody else some money in
Hollywood that person yes right that
doesn't matter but I have to say and I
don't agree with anything that he said
yeah um that when people and I am so on
the other side but you know when people
have said horrible things about Bush
which I think deservedly so that's okay
but when somebody says the opposite and
we have to have freedom of speech even
for the idiots even for the yes we
definitely have freedom of speech and
you know I remember one time years ago I
was in South Carolina doing a gig and
we're going to UM we haven't brunch and
and we had to leave soon because they
were closing the streets for Klan March
and I thought that's terrible and then I
thought no no this is good this is good
this should be seen it needs to be seen
it needs to be out there people need to
say these things out loud so you can see
what they are yes I agree they are did
you guys know the James Wood is
considered one of like the most hundred
most intelligent people in the United
States he's like immense a-- like top
tier person tell us does that change
your opinion that well that just goes to
I know some people in Mensa I gotta tell
some of the dumbest [ __ ] I've
ever met yeah that has no correlation
with being smart to having a high IQ to
be able to pass that Mensa test
no there's nothing but any Buckley he
was really that is whose ontology
politically yeah insane and you know
Sicily when you say I you know I admire
someone for expressing and informed
that's not an informed opinion that has
nothing to do with the thing he's upset
about has nothing to do with Barack
Obama it's like there are plenty of
reasons to criticize Barack Obama David
that's not what I'm upset about
right I say horrible things about Barack
Obama but they're accurate they're not
made up out of whole cloth and they
don't have an undertone of [ __ ] racism
right now granted that was only one
he has written a lot of stuff about the
NSA and all the other stuff that we all
don't like that he gonna say what I
started he should be upset at the
Patriot Act which allowed the other guy
do that [ __ ] so to pretend that this is
just Barack I mean you should criticize
Barack Obama but again pretending that
it's this administration that it's
somehow gonna be a threat that a forget
that god and the Patriot Act was Bush's
right as Bush Democrats and Republicans
God was doing it was Joey's registration
is everybody except for one congressman
or something or one something yes I'm
sure was one congresswoman yeah do is
the name of the Patriot Act business of
course mystic you know yeah but wasn't
that the beauty of the Patriot Act Pitts
if you're not a patriot if you can get
the hell out yeah yeah do we owe this
guy any credit whatsoever because at
least he's not going to the other main
things the anti women's stuff in the
anti-gay stuff he's at least going to
the policy stuff even if we don't agree
with it for him to say that about the
World War Two memorial I know that's
[ __ ] exposes him for it to be
uninformed it exposes him to be a white
lemming yeah a lemming right right what
is he's about as smart as Sarah Palin in
this instance yeah and so he's just you
just dismiss him but didn't didn't Obama
didn't the administration decide that
they were going to be the ones that were
gonna block actually blockade the thing
and lock it isn't that that pretty sure
the government now is this shut yeah
alright but all the parks in every state
are closed yeah all everything is closed
govern all of all the hands on the
Morrow's eyes are closed everything's
closed well they'll be open in about two
hours I'm here but you can't can I say
on the heels of that I saw some report
on TV with some guy was complaining that
you know that some guard wasn't letting
him into the World War Two memorial and
you know I hate flag pins
I hate flag pins thank you look first of
all I'll [ __ ] you ah I don't care um
they've become meaningless because
everybody wears a flag pin because what
if they see me not wearing a flag pin so
they become meaningless anyway so but
this guy was wearing a flag like a flag
get waved in his pocket it was bad
yeah well that's a human was a liar yeah
that's funny it was like cartoonish well
I always I refer to those but people who
wear the flag lapel pin
so that that's like an [ __ ] detector
right it's like I can tell I can tell
you're still an [ __ ]
and it you know it's it's the it's the
guy your tell you trying too much like
if I was an enemy of the United States
and I don't anybody know it the first
thing I will do and put that flag who
was it that was running for president
that didn't want to wear the pin and
everybody was Pitt was it Ron Paul one
of these I was mama who it was Obama it
was President Obama but now but now he
wears the flip now he wears it how he
wears the pin but now he wears it all
right that's the Rubin report brought to
you by Cooper comm they've got up to 75%
off cat and dog treats toys and more you
can get another 20% off using code RR
the link is right down below click it
and make your pet happy